The "Barbie" movie sells itself as having
something for everybody. But when it comes
to Ken, that may not be entirely true! From
silky smooth chests to the meaning behind a
"beach off," there's a lot about Barbie's
sidekick that only adults will get.
In director Greta Gerwig movie, it's quickly
established that Barbie has a personal theme
song of sorts — the Indigo Girls classic
"Closer to Fine." Ken initially seems
content to sing that song along with her. But
when he ventures out into the real world and
discovers a certain version of masculinity,
Ken no longer likes the song. At that point,
Ken discovers his own favorite
song, and it soon takes over as
the anthem for Barbieland's transition into
Kendom: "Push" by the band Matchbox Twenty.
Aside from director Gerwig being a fan, "Push"
was likely chosen because it sounds exactly like
the kind of song a dude-bro would be obsessed
with and want to sing to a woman he is trying
to woo. But those already familiar with the
song from its mid-'90s heyday immediately
realized there was a lot more going on there.
With lyrics like "I wanna take you for granted,"
the song gives us insight into Ken's state of
mind. After all, he had previously felt taken
advantage of by Barbie, so it makes sense
that Ken would like a song like "Push."
"But it's Barbie and Ken.
There is no just Ken."
While there seems to be at least a little bit of
body diversity among the Barbies in the movie,
the Kens are all pretty stereotypical in
that they're uniformly thin, chiseled,
and completely devoid of body hair. It's most
apparent with the two main Kens, played by Ryan
Gosling and Simu Liu's, given how often their
bare chests are visible. But it can also be seen,
or not seen, on the arms and legs of all the other
Kens. There's no visible hair on their bodies,
despite the fact that some of these actors
probably have some body hair in real life.
Sure enough, Liu confirmed to Allure that he
had to have his body waxed two different times
while filming "Barbie" to ensure that
smooth, hairless look. But that's not
all that went into making the actors look like
human-sized Ken dolls. Liu explained to Allure:
"We had to look glossy and plastic and there was
a lot of body paint applied every single day."
Younger viewers probably wouldn't have thought
twice about all that hairless skin. However,
those who have a few more years
on them certainly found themselves
wondering how all these adult men
could look so smooth and shiny.
Ken and Barbie are only in the real world
for about 10 seconds before Barbie starts
to experience what it's like to have men openly
gawk at her body and make gross comments about
it. When the pair encounter a group of
construction workers, the workers start
making a bunch of inappropriate sexual remarks,
all of which are directed at Barbie. It's then
that Barbie explicitly tells them that both
she and Ken are lacking in human genitalia.
Before that, however, Ken and Barbie's
inability to have sex is hinted at in a
hilariously awkward way that probably flew
over the heads of younger audience members.
Barbie is trying to get Ken to go home
so she can party with the other Barbies,
and he asks if he can stay the night.
She is confused, and inquires as to why
he would want to sleep over. Of course, he
doesn't have an answer, and ends up just as
baffled about why he even asked the question in
the first place. Later, Weird Barbie remarks,
"I'd like to see what smooth blob
[Ken's] packing in those shorts."
Weird Barbie's comment is further evidence
that the dolls have a vague sense of sexual
attraction to one another even though
they don't really know what to do with it.
"I'm coming with you."
"Okay."
Barbie and Ken learn most of the same truths about
the real world, only they absorb the information
in almost exactly opposite ways. Barbie is
disappointed to see that she hadn't fixed feminism
and that the world is in fact still a patriarchy.
Meanwhile, Ken couldn't be more thrilled to learn
that there is a place where men rule instead of
women. While exploring Los Angeles on his own,
Ken stumbles into a building where multiple
screens are showing visual representations
of masculinity throughout the years. Ken
becomes especially fixated on one recurring
figure in that montage — Sylvester Stallone.
After that, Ken bases much of what it means
to be a man on both Stallone himself and the
characters he plays. "Rocky" clearly makes
a major impression on him, as Ken is seen
wearing boxing gloves at one point when he first
arrives back in Barbieland. Ken's obsession with
horses as a sign of masculinity could also
be connected to Rocky Balboa's nickname,
"The Italian Stallion." But most obvious is
the white fur coat that Ken wears for a long
stretch of the movie, which is modeled after
a similar coat that Stallone is seen wearing
in the montage. Stallone was known to don
extravagant fur coats in the '80s, helping
to popularize them as a statement of not only
hyper-masculinity but also wealth and success.
"Did you bring your rollerblades?"
"I literally go nowhere without them."
Throughout some of the film, Barbie is in the
real world, searching for the girl that her doll
avatar belongs to. During her journey, she and Ken
end up at a high school. While Barbie confronts
Sasha in the school cafeteria, Ken is left on his
own to explore the high school. Before long, he
finds his way to the library. It's there that he
comes across several fake but hilariously-titled
books about the history of patriarchy and other
guy stuff. The books have names like "The
Origins of Patriarchy" and "Man Wars."
It's more than likely that those books
are meant to poke fun at Jordan Peterson
and other figures like him. Peterson's most
famous book — "12 Rules of Life" — has been
seen as pro-patriarchy, and he's been known
to complain about how masculinity is under
attack in modern society. Peterson has also
claimed that people are afraid to admit that
men hold the power because, in his view,
men are simply better at being in charge.
There's little doubt that Peterson would see
the changeover from Barbieland to Kendom as a
step in the right direction. It wouldn't be the
first time that a film takes Peterson's ideals
and mines them for villainy. For one, Olivia
Wilde was very upfront about the fact that
Peterson inspired Chris Pine's wretchedly
evil character in "Don't Worry Darling."
The opening scenes of "Barbie" show how all
of the Barbies in Barbieland are BFFs. They
all love each other, respect each other, and
celebrate each other's success. While that
mostly seems true for the Kens as well,
Beach Ken and Tourist Ken seem to have a
pretty bitter rivalry. Much of it stems
from them competing for the attention of
Stereotypical Barbie. But it also seems like
they simply don't like each other very much.
How do you settle a dispute in Barbieland?
Well, it's later established that weapons
don't exist there. Moreover, the Kens
don't exactly seem like the type to
get into vicious physical altercations. So
it's suggested that they have a beach-off,
which sounds innocent enough — until phrases
like this start getting thrown around:
"I would beach you off right now, Ken."
"I'll beach off with you anyday, Ken."
Sounds a little like they are saying something
else, doesn't it? There are only a few gags in
"Barbie" that are meant to elicit chuckles from
the adults while going over the heads of children,
and the whole concept of getting "beached off"
is perhaps the dirtiest of them all. That said,
having a snippet of it included in some of
the trailers was definitely an indication
that a little bit of grown-up naughtiness was
going to be snuck into this PG-13 movie.
In order to take Barbieland back from the Kens,
the Barbies have to be reprogrammed
back to their original selves. This way,
they're no longer the meek, subservient
women that they've been turned into.
"Okay, ladies! Let's do this."
In one of the movie's funniest sequences, some
of the reprogrammed Barbies pretend to need
reassurance about their looks or have something
mansplained to them. The point is so that no Ken
doll can resist giving his full attention to them.
There are some obvious ploys, like the Barbie
that pretends she never saw "The Godfather" and
needs a Ken to explain the entire movie to her.
"Leave the gun. Take the cannolis."
But one of the more obscure ones has a Ken
explaining the role that Stephen Malkmus played
in the evolution of rock 'n' roll in relation
to Lou Reed and the Velvet Underground. Most
know Reed and his former band, but only those
with a love of '90s indie music will recognize
Malkmus as the frontman for celebrated rock
group Pavement. Pavement's biggest mainstream
success occurred in the early-to-mid-'90s — and
even then, they never exactly lit up the charts.
Malkmus responded to the shout-out
in an Instagram story, initially
teasing that he was going to get his lawyers
involved but saying the band is "pro-Greta"
Gerwig. So he seemed to appreciate the
mentioning of his name in the movie.
"Barbie" is absolutely jam-packed
with references to pop culture,
especially films. The films mentioned range from
timeless classics like "The Wizard of Oz" all the
way down to obscure films from the French New
Wave. But there is one scene in particular that
is almost entirely based on another sequence from
a different movie. It's far beyond a mere Easter
egg or background reference and instead is an
outright love letter to the film that inspired it.
Though the big song and dance battle between
the Kens initially starts on the beach, they
are all soon magically transported to a dream-like
space of blues and pinks, with everyone dressed in
black. While some have suggested that the outfits
recall what Danny Zuko wears in much of "Grease,"
the whole scene is a much more obvious tribute to
the iconic dream ballet sequence from "Singin' in
the Rain." Released in 1952, the legendary musical
predates both Ken and Barbie by a few years,
and is certainly one of the oldest pieces of pop
culture history that "Barbie" pays homage to.
There have been a lot of different
variations of Barbie and Ken dolls
over the years. Longtime Barbie fans had
a blast trying to see how many different
dolls they recognized as characters in
the movie, especially those that only
had a quick line or two, or only appeared
in the background and said nothing at all.
"And Alan!"
With few exceptions, almost every Barbie
and Ken mentioned in the movie was a real
doll at some point. Remarkably, this also
includes the canceled doll Sugar's Daddy Ken.
Also referenced and standing alongside Ken in the
movie is Earring Magic Ken, who has an even wilder
history that older viewers surely remember.
Upon his release in 1993, many were quick to
identify that Earring Magic Ken's clothing was
clearly inspired by the fashions popular in the
gay club scene at the time. As for the ring the
doll wore around its neck, let's just say that
in addition to "Gay Ken," Earring Magic Ken was
also sometimes referred to as "C--- Ring Ken."